do you think about your mortality
are you afraid of death
so
fear of death is like one of the most
fundamental fears that each of us has we
might be not even aware of it it
requires to look inside to even
recognize that it's
out there and there is still let's say
this property
of uh nature that if things would last
forever then they would be also boring
to us
the fact that the things change in some
way
gives any meaning to them
i also you know found out that
it seems to be
very healing to people to
have
these short experiences
like i guess psychedelic experiences in
which they experience
death of self
in which they let go of this fear and
then
maybe can even increase the appreciation
of the moment
it seems that many people they uh
they
they can easily comprehend find
the fact that their money is finite
while they don't see that time is finite
i have this like a discussion with ilya
from time to time he's saying you know
man like
the lack will pass very fast at some
point i will be 40 50 60 70 and then
it's over
this is true which also makes me believe
that you know that every single moment
it is so unique
that
should be appreciated and this also
makes me think that i should be acting
on my life
because otherwise it will pass
i also like this framework of thinking
from jeff bezos on regret ministation
that like i would like
if i will be at that deathbed to look
back on my life
and
and not regret that i haven't
done something it's usually you might
regret that you haven't
tried i'm fine with failing
i haven't tried
uh what's the nature eternal occurrence
tried to live a life that if you had to
live it infinitely many times
that would be though
you'd be okay with
that kind of life
so try to live it optimally
i can say that it's almost like a
unbelievable to me
where i am in my life i'm extremely
grateful for actually people
whom i met i would say i think that i'm
decently smart and so on
[Music]
but i think that
actually to great extent where i am has
to do with the people who i met
would you be okay
if after this conversation you died
so
if i'm dead then it kind of
i don't have a choice anymore
so in some sense there's like plenty of
things that i would like to try out in
my life
[Music]
i feel that you know i'm gradually going
one by one and i'm just doing them
i think that the list will be always
infinite yeah
so might as well go today
yeah i mean to be clear i'm not looking
forward to die
i would say if there is no choice i
would accept it
but like uh in some sense i'm
if there would be a choice if there
would be possibility to leave i would
fight for a living
i find um it's more
honest than real to think about you know
dying today at the end of the day
that seems to me to at least to my brain
more on a slap in the face
as opposed to i still have 10 years
like today
then then i'm much more about
appreciating the cup and the table and
so on and less about like silly worldly
accomplishments and all those kinds of
things
we we we have in the company a person
who say at some point found out that
they have cancer and that also gives you
know huge perspective with respect to
what matters now yeah and you know often
people in situations like that they
conclude that actually what matters is
human connection
and
love and uh that's people conclude also
if you have kids because kids is family
you uh i think tweeted
we don't assign the minus infinity
reward to our death such a reward would
prevent us from taking any risk we
wouldn't be able to cross the road in
fear of being hit by a car so in the
objective function you mentioned fear of
death might be fundamental to the human
condition so
as i said let's assume that they're like
a reward functions in our brain
and
and the interesting thing is
even realization how different reward
functions can play with your behavior
as a matter of fact i wouldn't say that
you should assign infinite
negative reward to anything because that
messes up the math
the math doesn't work out it doesn't
work out and as you said even you know
uh government or some insurance
companies you said they assign 9 million
dollars to human life yeah and i'm just
saying it with respect to
that might be a harsh statement to
ourselves but in some sense that there
is a finite value of our own life
i'm trying to put it from
perspective of being
less
of being more egoless
yeah and realizing fragility of my own
life
and
in some sense
the
fear of death
might prevent you from acting
because anything can cause death
yeah and i'm sure actually if you were
to put death in the objective function
there's probably so many aspects to
death and fear of death and
uh realization of death and mortality
there's just whole components of
finiteness
of not just your life but every
experience and so on you're gonna have
to
formalize mathematically and also you
know that might lead to
you're spending a lot of compute cycles
on this like a
and deliberating this terrible future
instead of experiencing now
and and in some sense it's also kind of
unpleasant simulation to run in your
head
you